hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar serum free expansion of nk cells
with
k562 based feeder systems for clinical
application i'm susie valdez of labrutz
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by gibco by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit their site at
thermofisher.com backslash gibco
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits
without further ado let me welcome our
speaker dr dean lee professor of
pediatrics and demarco family endowed
chair in cell based therapy at
nationwide children's hospital welcome
dr lee you may now begin your
presentation sir
thanks everyone
um so it's really a privilege to talk to
you all today and uh thanks for joining
us thanks to thermo fisher for inviting
me to do this um we've had a pretty good
um four or five year collaboration with
thermo fisher around um
media uh and i'll i'll spend a good part
of the talk today uh talking about that
um but just to go sort of get everybody
oriented um just a brief introduction
around bone marrow transplant and how
that has
informed what we do with cell therapy a
little bit of
sort of past history of nk cell
therapies um
starting about two decades ago and uh
how that's evolved now into what we're
doing with
cell therapy with
expansion with k562 based feeder cells
and then you know even all the way into
what that means for us for clinical
applications as well as
commercialization
uh and how really this this
collaboration with thermo fisher has
been an important part of getting to
what is the best possible product so
um
so the um
the idea of bone marrow transplant um
was originally just how can you rescue
someone from high-dose chemotherapy uh
so the initial um i guess experience
with
with chemotherapy and radiation in
treating cancer was one drug at a time
and
trying to figure out what the highest
doses were that could be tolerated and
then we went to sort of combining
multiple different types of chemotherapy
so we'd avoid resistance or or combining
chemotherapy and radiation but all of
those approaches work by killing cells
that grow fast
and the other cells in your body that
grow fast are your hair
the lining of your mucous membranes and
your bone marrow because you're
constantly making new blood new red
blood cells platelets neutrophils
lymphocytes those are constantly being
made by your bone marrow so the limiting
factor for how much you can give to kill
your cancer is how much the rest of your
body can tolerate um and not your hair
because you know you probably trade
being bald for being cancer-free that's
that's probably
a no-brainer
we have lots of other ways to feed you
if you have bad mucositis um we can get
nutrition into you for for quite a while
um while that heals
but without bone marrow um and a
functioning production of of the blood
uh cells that are necessary from your
bone marrow you really can't live very
long so so anyway bone marrow was just
rescuing you from what would have been
lethal doses of chemotherapy or
radiation
however what we found out was that it
was not
just the high doses of chemotherapy and
radiation it was the fact that we were
transplanting an entirely new immune
system
so when you get when you get a bone
marrow transplant is a whole lot of stem
cells you get those bone marrow stem
cells but you also get nk cells in
dendritic cells and b cells and platelet
precursors and t cells and nkt cells and
all of that is part of the milieu of the
transplant when we give it to the
recipient
unfortunately for 40 years we've really
not done much in terms of manipulating
that product other than
selecting stem cells or wiping out t
cells that's that's been the biggest
part of what we've done for for 40 years
but there's a lot of cells in that and
we don't we don't have a lot of control
over it
so um so anyway trying to understand
what we're giving as an immune system to
a patient has really become a
critical and important part of bone
marrow transplantation for the last
20 years especially
and for me as an nk cell
biologist and and looking at nk cells as
um
as potential immunotherapy
this is one of the few one of the few
figures out there that sort of look at
nk cells as being sort of the center of
the immunologic universe and nk cells
are really important in their direct
response to cancer by by recognizing
killing cancer or virus-infected cells
but they also have this really important
uh role in communicating to the rest of
the immune system so they they produce
cytokines and
cell interactions
that activate a mature dendritic cells
that lead to b cell activation class
switching and antibody production that
activate and recruits to the local micro
environment cd4 and cd8 t cells and nkt
cells and improve the interaction of
dendritic cells to t cells they lyse
tumors that release antigens to
derivative cells and so this innate
response by nk cells to cancer is very
largely what triggers the rest of the
adaptive immune response to cancer so
they're really critically important
however
nk cells have to be produced at a pretty
regular basis by the bone marrow they're
also made by the bone marrow and so just
bone marrow
infiltration by leukemia itself is
enough to decrease nk cell numbers um or
bone marrow suppression that we have um
from other types of cancer that impact
uh bone marrow function
and then there the cancer itself learns
to
produce lots of suppressive factors to
nk cells tgf beta in the cancer
microenvironment ido is an enzyme that
cleaves tryptophan and creates
suppressive molecules in the kinerinen
family
tin 3 other checkpoint inhibitors
hypoxia low glucose all these things
further impact nk cell function and then
you come to us with your cancer and we
give you chemotherapy or radiation and
we wipe out every last nk cell that's
left so there's now nothing that we have
in in this hole that's such a critical
part of connecting the rest of the
immune response to cancer and so we've
seen this now as as being the
the therapeutic opportunity can we
restore nk cell function after those
high levels of chemotherapy or radiation
can we improve nk cell reconstitution
after transplant can we rapidly recover
nk cells
that are suppressed after chemotherapy
and radiation so they can do their job
better and hopefully we can improve the
improved cures overall
so this as a concept um really uh took
hold in the late 1990s
and further expanded in in the early
part of this millennium with the advent
of apheresis so we could now get a donor
um to sit by the apheresis machine and
collect a large number of peripheral
blood cells in this in the far right
yellow bag above the top of this machine
and give everything else back to him so
we don't need the red blood cells we
don't need the platelets we don't need
the plasma we'll we'll just run him run
his blood through a circuit collect all
the white blood cells give everything
back
and so doing that
you then have to take the
the blood that you have
and the other blood cells and remove the
t cells because the t cells are going to
be likely to cause gbh in this setting
and what you have left is an nk cell
product that you can then deliver to a
patient and lots of different
groups
across the world did this
um and so this is just maybe a dozen or
so papers uh
around 10 years ago that described this
approach where they would do apheresis
and cd3 depletion some of them did 23
depletion and cd50 selection some of
them tried to expand with some cytokines
um but all of them ended up with around
one to two times ten to the seventh per
kilo of the number of cells that could
be delivered to the patient
and that was it you had you had one shot
you could infuse those cells and then
you were done so it really meant that um
that it was
really important to get the patient to
then
the nk cells to expand in the patient in
order for those numbers of nk cells to
actually do their job because they're
it's a that's a pretty small number
of total nk cells
so
so that created a whole field of people
trying to look at can we grow the nk
cells can we actually get them in the
lab to expand to large numbers
so that we have enough numbers to treat
because this is like a drug right you
have to have enough cells to actually do
something to the cancer
so my experience in
nk cells actually started because i was
trying to grow t cells i was working
with lawrence cooper at md anderson and
we
in collaboration with carl june had
developed a wide variety of these
artificial antigen presenting cells
based on a cell called k562
and their purpose was to provide
anagenic stimulation to a car t cell
along with co-stimulation and cytokine
activation in a way to grow um large
numbers of um of t cells
however
we found out that um surprise to us uh
every once in a while we would get nk
cells to grow instead and so we started
manipulating the system to see if we
could intentionally get nk cells to grow
and ended up with a system that that
allowed us to create really large
numbers of nk cells
that were highly functional and the
thing that we um kind of fell on was the
fact that we were we had a couple of
cell lines that expressed il-21
and as you can see in the left graph
here they helped promote log phase
expansion for many many weeks on end
where when you grew the cells with il-15
they would grow for a little bit and
then after about three or four weeks
they would just peter out
and we determined that this was actually
from a variety of different
effects that il-21 had the most
important of which is probably on the
far right graph which is that the il-21
induces longer telomeres in the nk cells
so that they are just healthier and able
to continue proliferation
if your telomeres get too short that
cells can't divide and they ultimately
die of senescence and that's what was
happening with the il-15 which you see
here
after two weeks they actually had 10
percent shorter telomeres rather than 10
longer telomeres
so the other thing that happened was it
changed their function and in the middle
figure you can see where
fresh nk cells they produce interferon
and tnf as we all know when you expanded
them for too long with il15 and they
started to become senescent they made
less interferon and less tnf and when
you expanded them with il21 they
actually increased the amounts of
cytokines that they made interfering
gamma and tnf and they started making a
lot of their own il-2
which
we still are trying to understand the
mechanism of this and is is really a
novel feature of nk cells that are
activated
numbers
we have what seems like good function
they make cytokines they have nice
telomeres
so that all doesn't matter unless they
can kill cancer and sure enough these
expanded cells actually killed better
than wild type nk cells um that were
taken straight out of the blood and they
would kill almost anything we put them
with lymphoma cells aml
neuroblastoma neural crest tumors
osteosarcoma
carcinomas melanoma colon pancreatic
we've done breasts we've done brain
tumors
there are individual tumor cell lines
which are more or less sensitive to nk
cells but there isn't any one type of
cancer that wouldn't respond to this um
we wouldn't respond to these expanded nk
cells and so we really felt like we had
something that was
going to be a medical
broadcast in therapy
so just as a um hopefully this will come
up and this is a video of a
um
atrt cell line this is a really
difficult to treat uh cancer in children
a brain tumor
atypical territory rhabdoid tumor and
that's the big cell with the the red
nucleus
the nk cell is the tiny little uh block
cell with a white halo and you'll see
when i play press play the nk cell is
kind of feeling along the surface trying
to decide whether this is good bad or
bad cell and kill it and once it makes
that decision it's really a rapid event
in other kinetic studies where they have
looked at the degranulation event
the initial release of granules to kill
the target happens within 90 seconds of
an nk cell encountering the tumor cell
and making that decision that that it's
a bad cell
so that's what we'd like to happen
inside of patients we'd like to see
these nk cells find tumor kill the tumor
and and
rapidly induce a response
well along the way
um we found out a lot of other things
about the il-21 so il-21
signals through stat3 and we have now
learned a whole lot about what stat 3
turns on inside of a cell in terms of
gene transcription i won't go through
all of this but in in the bottom right
very kind of about the middle let's
let's take that one the set of genes
that are turned on by il-21 and naive nk
cells the expanded cells have even more
genes that are il-21 responsive
um and those are in the far right um
mostly congregated into
mechanisms of dna processes and repair
regulation of of cell proliferation uh
regulation of replication and glycolysis
which is we'll see in a little bit is
really important important to their
their function
they have to have they have to be fit
metabolically
um and then a variety variety of other
gene expression families that relate to
again transcription and biosynthetic
processes and
cytokine signaling
so
one of those that i mentioned before is
about
telomeres and so we found out that
actually stat three turns on the
it's called telomerase
um and then we went and looked at some
patients who have stat three
deficiencies a disease called job
syndrome and found out that the
telomeres of their nk cells were
actually quite short compared to
normal patients
um the expansion process and il-21
activates the cells and turns on high
expression of lots of different
receptors so these receptors shown in
this figure on the right
are all the receptors that an nk cell
uses to see its universe to try to
understand whether cells are dangerous
or safe and so these having more of
these receptors is really kind of
important in terms of their surveillance
um they are less apoptotic so there's a
there's quite a number of genes that are
differentially regulated between il15
and l21 that are related to cell death
in particular the gene bim
and that seems to be regulated by some
micro rna the most differentially
regulated micro rna between il15 and l21
is one called mir 124
and we have really some some very
interesting data about how that mirror
regulates apoptosis and cell division
i mentioned uh metabolism so
the expansion of nk cells actually
results in this huge change in their
ability to
undergo glycolysis and their glycolytic
reserve this is in part related to in
the figure on the bottom left
up regulation of glucose transport genes
and several genes related to the glucose
metabolism cycle um
phosphokinases
and
other pieces of the of metabolism that
allow nk cells to really be high
utilizers of glucose
so
how much has this actually changed um
it's maybe it's a little harder to see
on this scale
side
um this was really a
a
project that was defined to try to
understand the difference between
licensed cells and on unlicensed cells
but look at the scale on resting cells
you can see their glycolytic capacity is
somewhere in the 10 to 15 range where
the scale for expanded nk cells is in
the 60 to 80 range they have hugely
upturned abilities
to to metabolize glucose and thereby use
that energy
in their killing and migration
all right so we have
we have a way to make the cells and now
we had to figure out how to
grow them and manufacture them at
clinical grade and scale and so what we
ended up with was a feeder cell shown at
the bottom here in this kind of orange
cell that is genetically modified as i
mentioned with il 21 and
41 bb
and we ended up with a fairly simple
process of sending our donor to the
blood bank they would donate a unit of
blood just like anyone else
um the buffy coat or the white cell
fraction of that unit is usually thrown
usually use that for anything
um but we had actually determined that
it was a great source of the nk cells
and then get rid of the t cells by cd3
depletion and then once a week add our
new feeder cell to those cells and
produce essentially a highly pure
product of nk cells that could either be
infused or we hoped cryopreserved and
infused later
and i'll get a little bit uh
i don't remember if i included that data
um anyway crowd preservation of nk cells
has been a a little bit of a controversy
and a problem but for us we really felt
like it was important to validate that
approach
because in order for cell therapy to
really be broadly applied you have to be
able to freeze the cells and ship them
and and send them save them if you have
to link your patient need to the
manufacturing in the gmp facility it
really becomes cumbersome
uh all right so um just a few pieces so
how we're going to think about then
moving this to the clinic that there are
some some really essential
considerations
if you think about nk cells as a drug
these all make kind of sense because
these are the same kinds of
of things that you would want for
developing a new drug for
for cancer
so we needed to overcome some issues of
donor variability um you want your drug
to be consistent and you don't want your
responses to vary every time you choose
you know a new um
a new drug
you want to understand the dose you want
to be able to define potency
you want to know how long it lasts
you want which is sort of the equivalent
of pharmacokinetics
does the
does do the nk cells actually home
and go to the tumor site that's the same
as pharmacodynamics
in drug studies are the mechanisms of
resistance and how specific
is the nk cell to your tumor type so the
same kinds of things you would want to
know in a drug
so we've
we've actually tried to address all of
these different issues in the area of nk
cell therapy by looking at genetic
screening to to solve the problem of
variability
as i'm just been describing by looking
at in vitro expansion so that we can
solve the problem of dose
cytokine preactivation with the aisle 21
that i showed you greatly enhances
potency
understanding senescence and cytokine
support so the cells last and have
better persistence
we haven't really talked much about
homing but there's a lot of different
addressings on nk cells that help
determine where they go and so we're
trying to better understand which are
the best nk cells to go to each
different type of tumor
we're looking at the tumor
microenvironment as i mentioned tgf beta
and the oral hydrocarbon receptors
hypoxia checkpoints and then
in order to enhance specificity nk cells
are actually really nicely situated for
that because they're what mediates most
anti-cancer antibodies so most
antibodies need to target a particular
antigen in the tumor and then it's the
nk cell that recognizes the antibody and
kills the tumor so we already have lots
of examples of
of helping nk cells be really specific
against cancer with antibody
combinations and then most recently
translating those antibodies into
chimeric energy receptors just as
they've been done for t cells that you
can do that also for cars
all right
so we now have this expansion platform
and we have a lot of questions we need
to answer in order to get this to a
clinical product
what donors are we going to use do we
need to a foresa donors or can we just
collect the peripheral blood can we get
rid of adequate numbers of the t cells
so it doesn't cause gbh will the cell
survive cryopreservation which feeder
cell is best and what media is best
because all of that has to somehow be
incorporated into our clinical trial
design and manufacturing process so that
we get up end up with a a
good solid cell therapy product
all right we answered most of those
questions and we decided to move forward
with our first
clinical trial which was in the context
of transplant
and so the way we constructed this um
this treatment plan was to take a
standard transplant that we had lots of
experience with um using a
haploidentical donor
um which used flu dairy bean and melflin
as the conditioning regimen a stem cell
infusion on day zero we use
post-transplant cyclophosphamide at day
three and four and what we decided to do
is just layer right over the top of that
the addition of donor and k cells
now one of the a variety of reasons for
doing this one of them is that like i
said at the very beginning
historically we have not had any control
over what we delivered to a patient in
terms of the immune context
of the immune content of the the stem
cell product we just gave whatever we
collected
so here we want to control this we want
to actually give large numbers of nk
cells from the donor along with those
donor stem cells
the second is that we were starting to
understand pretty clearly that although
post-transplant cyclophosphamide that's
given here on day 3 and 4 is really
effective at reducing t cells that cause
gbh it also wipes out nk cells
and so we decided to give two more doses
of nk cells afterwards at day 7 and day
28 to further push the nk cell
reconstitution
in these patients
so this started as a
as a clinical trial in 2012 at md
anderson we published the phase one data
in 2017 and just a couple weeks ago the
phase two data was released
um in the british journal of hematology
and that's these results here which is
that compared to very carefully um uh
curated case match controls for the from
the center for uh international bone
marrow transplant research cibmtr
um you can see that just changing
the addition of nk cells reduced relapse
rates from 38 to 4
increased overall survival from 44 to 60
66 percent so a 50 increase uh half
again
um from what the prior survival rate was
um and that was even more pronounced in
particular patients who were
negative for donor specific antibodies
went from 44 to 72
so nothing else changed the only thing
we did was was optimize good nk cell
function
in these patients and so we're really
hopeful this is going to move on to now
um
a multi-institutional phase two uh trial
to really
verify the um the applicability of this
approach
so we were able to do a couple of um
uh correlative studies with these
patients one was to understand whether
that um
i showed you the ship the figure that
these nk cells obtain a really high
expression of all these
activating receptors and sure enough in
our patients we can still identify them
even two weeks after the cells were
infused
down here in uh bright red in the lower
right hand uh corner there's lots of the
nk cells in those patients that are
still this this bright um hyper
functional phenotype that look very much
like the cells that we infused which is
right in the middle
we're also able to show
actually i have some i've got i had some
animations there yes so these two here
really showing that they have some
standard nk cells but they still have
these these high bright nk cells
um so in other
studies of haplotransplant with
post-transplant cyclophosphamide um
they've described the reconstitution of
nk cells and t cells and at every single
time point t cells dominate
here we were able to give high doses of
nk cells the nk cells dominate in fact
every single patient at every single
time point had more nk cells in their
peripheral blood than they had t cells
so we've now actually completely
reversed the pro the normal um
reconstitution that happens after this
kind of transplant and biased it towards
a transplant that favors nk cells and
anti-tumor
activity
um so just sort of one last piece around
the feeder cell because i don't want to
uh
this this really is more more about the
media and growing themselves in the
theater cell itself
well we um we ended up not being able to
patent the feeder cell and so
there wasn't at the time a lot of
interest in nk cells in fact we had this
external ip review in 2011 that looked
at this and they said no there's really
going to be no market for nk cells and
we don't really think it's worth you
know uh filing a patent on t cells are
the thing
so don't bother with nk cells
well lo and behold five years later um
nature biotechnology has their cover
story about nk cells as the next big
thing and as you know now it's where
there's just been an explosion in nk
cell companies and trials and approaches
and there's a lot of reasons why nk
cells really might be
have that have a niche in cell therapy
for for cancer
so to do that right the next thing now
that we've got clinical trials done and
all of my work is is in an academic uh
facility we really do need to think
about what it means to translate this
to
the clinic but also what it means to
commercialize it to something that can
be broadly distributed to everybody who
wants and needs it
translation which is where i live most
of my life is how do i take stuff from
my lab that is with 25 gram mice and
translate that into 75 kilogram men
right there's a 3 000 fold difference in
the size between a mouse and a man and
that makes a big difference in
manufacturing right i can no longer grow
my cells in a little vial
i need to think about big scale
manufacturing
translation
um so commercial laser sorry go back and
forth
for commercialization
you're thinking about not what is what
do i need to do in a gnp facility to
grow
cells for 20 patients
of my 75 kilogram men but is it
practical to grow
nk cells for 20 000 patients because
that's how many aml patients are going
to need this if it's actually
going to work how many every year right
we're going to have to have thousands of
times more
nk cells to make this broadly applicable
in the translation side i think about
scale up and process development how do
i go from the stuff i use in my lab
serum and media and the feeder cells
and make technicians
able to do that in a gmp facility and
and make a gmp
fda
product
um i need to understand the identity of
those the purity the safety but i don't
even have to think about potency
according to the fda until we get to a
phase three trial where on the
commercialization side it's all about
process optimization what are the cost
of goods is there an fda compliant
process do i have to worry about bovine
spongiform encephalitis when i order my
serum and of course yes you do
is it efficient is it you want processes
that are independent of a technician
that are in closed automated systems now
you have to think about potency and how
do we measure potency of every batch and
how do we package it how do we
distribute it
so the questions that you need to answer
on the commercialization side are really
quite different than than what we
normally do in an academic facility on
the translation side
and the goals of that commercialization
are to minimize your cost time
variability t-cell contamination and
technician time and to maximize your
yield your purity your function and
stability
so um the last piece i'll just mention
about the feeder cells since i said that
we couldn't uh patent it what actually
helped getting this to
a company was the fact that we had a
collaboration with a group at university
of central florida that had
worked on taking the feeder cells
and basically
exploding them with nitrogen
into small little particles almost like
exosomes and in this way being able to
produce a cell-free
membrane material that had all the same
um
stimulation abilities and growth
capabilities of nk cells
without having the concern that this was
a cancer-related fetus so this is like
one of those first steps of
commercialization
from a from a
um academic
uh perspective the fda doesn't really
care if i use k562 feet or cells they're
okay with that i irradiate them we we
make sure there's no peter cells left in
the product but from a commercial
perspective you really it's much much
harder to rely on that cell line as your
um
as your your expansion product so
in order to change this part of the
manufacturing i'm going to spend a
little bit of time on this because it's
important when we get to the media part
you have to verify you have to show
equivalency to the fda you have to show
them that if i grow these cells with the
nanoparticles they are just the same as
if i grew them with the feeder cells
otherwise the fda is going to say it's a
different drug
so we had to show that they grow the
same that they grow just like i showed
you in one of the very first slides that
il-15 they they plateau and stop at
about two weeks and il-21 they keep
growing log phase growth same thing
happens if you use the particles as if
you use the feeder cells their
cytotoxicity is the same we had to look
at their cytokine profiles we had to do
high dimension cytop for their phenotype
and show that it didn't matter
a little bit hard to see here but in
green above and below are the
ordinary nk cells you would take from
peripheral blood and in blue purple and
red are the nk cells that we we would
expand either with feeder cells at one
institution feeder cells at another
institution or particles of the company
they all overlapped together we had to
do rna-seq and do sort of deep dive into
what these cells look like and again
they're
they're they overlay each other
perfectly in terms of their um their
gene expression profiles so it really
didn't matter we had to prove it but it
really didn't matter how you grew the
cells whether it was a feeder cell or a
particle as long as the il-21 was
present as long as the rest of the
stimulation
pieces were were present
i mentioned that we had to do some scale
up but we're still further scaling up um
to go from mouse to humans but also to
go from human academic studies to
commercial studies you know i can grow
everything i need for a mouse and a
little t-175 flask but to grow enough
for a
um clinical trial i need to grow a
thousand of those flasks or a hundred
hyper floss or forty g rex plus it's
just
it's just too much um so we've moved to
other kinds of systems um like the
zuri which is shown here on the far
right a big five liter bag is uh
with automated feeding and
consistent um
uh
[Music]
consistent um
pumping in of that media so you don't
have to actually change media like you
do manually
um we're using um the the prodigy as
part of our processing base so that we
don't have to have open systems for
collecting the initial material our
particle manufacturing is now all um
sort of moving along in a closed system
so all these pieces kind of have to work
together
so so seeing how
the hurdles are when you go from the lab
to the clinic or from the clinic to
commercialization or when you change one
little part of your manufacturing
it wasn't really simple
to find a serum free media for feeder
cell expansion and we knew we were going
to have to move in that direction
because fetal calf serum is just it's a
problem it's it's hard to source it's
expensive
it's variable uh there are concerns for
safety
um and all of those are things that you
would want to get rid of uh if you're
really going to move this to a more
universal platform
so our first project that we interacted
with thermo fisher
was to compare every
uh gmp grade
serum free media we could find um
fishers or others
and see like how would they behave
and so the first question is can you
even support proliferation and so in the
top left we compared our standard which
was rpmi and fetal calf serum just for
one week just that initial week of
expansion with some others and
really surprised to find that the aim
five with this serum replacement media
actually outperformed i was i was only
hoping to find that we were
something that was equivalent not
something was actually better
when we did two-week expansion um the
difference was uh still significant and
quite meaningful it's about
two to three times as many cells if you
grew them with aim five
um we did some further like
maybe to go through these um so the top
left was all the different media we
picked the the four winners we did a
full two week expansion in the bottom uh
left then we narrowed it down to really
do lots of different donors
in the top right
and then ultimately
the last question for us was what what
actually made the difference was it the
change in media from rpmi to aim five or
was it the change in serum
to icsr
and when we did that actually everything
looked the same so
so ultimately what we found out was
that
the benefit that the serum replacement
caused was one
that was most noticeable by biologic
variability of the donors
so if you look at the top right there
are some donors that look exactly the
same the lines go pretty much straight
across from from fbs to icsr and then
there are some that significantly
increase well it really depends on that
donor if that donor likes the serum you
give it then it grows really well
and the serum free media didn't matter
so much
if the donor didn't like the serum then
changing it to serum free media it
helped a lot so what it did more than
just improve
outcomes was to
normalize outcomes to make them more
consistent which is probably even more
important from a commercial perspective
right you really want to have a good
robust consistent platform um to grow
them on
so but that's not enough right we need
to know now also does it change the
functional profile um so we had to look
at cytotoxicity we had to look at
degranulation we had to look at cytokine
production
and if anything the serum free media was
better
what not worse does it change the
phenotypic profile we looked at all
those different receptors again and most
of the time it was the same
but in a few cases it was actually
better when it came to
some of the cytokines or receptors like
cd16
some of the pathways of activation might
be a little bit different for some
reason there was a little bit less trail
but the cytotoxicity wasn't affected so
that was okay
and then we had to look at lots a lot
variation so did we just get a good lot
and maybe there's just as much variation
in the serum replacement as there was in
serum and that was actually not the case
so we compared all those same features
proliferation
cytotoxicity cytokine production
degranulation i'm across six different
icsr lots and it was all
quite uniform
in the last
rite
was an attempt we had to try to
understand a little bit better how to
feed the cells and
you know if you let the cells sit there
long enough they eventually
stop growing if you don't change the
media and the question was
do they stop growing because of a lack
of nutrients or because of a buildup of
toxic byproducts and um
we couldn't really answer that question
they both are inversely proportional and
the more you use up their your toxic
byproducts the more you i'm sorry the
more you use up your nutrients the more
you release toxic byproducts so it ended
up being a little bit of wash but what
we did end up with is at least having
some guidelines for understanding what
the limits were for good healthy cells
and we can't get below about a gram per
liter of glucose before your
your nk cells start to crash so at least
we have now some hard biochemical
guidelines for understanding how cells
need to grow
well that experience
helped thermo fisher
move along in actually making a brand
new media
just for nk cells
the first one that i was just talking
about m5 was really made for t cells um
i don't know 15 years ago it was quite a
while ago
and the immune cell
supplement was just sort of broadly
defined for immune cells but they wanted
to understand if they really went from
first principles and and understood
better um
the
the kinds of biochemicals that needed to
be utilized uh just like i was showing
you on that last slide if we understand
glucose utilization and amino acids and
vitamins and
minerals and all those other pieces that
are part of your
your media can we define something that
is actually optimized for nk cells
well like i
showed you before right this is not
going to be an easy experiment
um it was going to have to have multiple
comparison arms with um pieces that were
as consistent as possible between them
we had we still have donor variability
so we're going to have to do as many
donors as we could to wash out that part
of the variability and we're going to
have to look at fold proliferations out
of toxicity cytokine production their
gene expression analysis their
metabolite analysis anyway um long story
short i think thermo fisher really hit
the nail on the head
and that new media the nk expander
worked even better than the m5 did for
us and and many times better than than
rpmi without any loss of function
so we're really able to have nice
consistent high level expansion
of these cells
that retain their function
um so anyway this has been a great uh
collaboration with thermo and we've been
able to
benefit from that by uh by adopting some
of these media
and hopefully being able to provide some
good data back to them as well and as
they
move their product along
so i'll end with just a couple of slides
about where do we go next um and how do
we now take this platform and move it
into something that is even more
applicable to uh to treating large
number patients or specific disease
types
so the first is
to really change how we think about
donors um i mentioned at the beginning
that that
um there's a lot of donor variability
and that's one of those things you want
to control for
but the field has actually moved along
in several steps
the first nk cell studies were all done
with autologous enquiry cells because
they're the safest obviously if you get
your own cells back there's they're
probably not going to hurt you
but that situation um
was really fraught with problems of of
failing
because of the cells themselves so
um we tried to do
initially uh like late 90s early 2000s
some autologous cells
studies were done in lymphoma and nobody
ever saw any responses well we thought
that was probably because
the nk cells themselves were a little
bit dysfunctional
and so we did some experiments to see if
expansion would improve the function of
those cells and it does they completely
restore their function
but the patients themselves are really
um
so beat up by the chemotherapy that some
patients we just couldn't get enough
cells to start from and so we couldn't
get enough cells for adequate doses
so that's the problem with the first box
is that you have failed expansions you
just can't treat everybody
the second
move then is to go to family donors and
identify um allogeneic donors for each
patient which is we usually refer to as
a haploidentical donors and in that
setting sometimes patients don't have a
donor or they don't have an ideal donor
they have two or three people who could
donate some cells a mom and a dad and a
brother
for most of our kids or uh you know a
son or a daughter
um but not everybody has a donor so then
you have patients who just can't be
treated
so the real question for us is could we
identify what we thought were
the ideal characteristics of a donor and
collect large numbers of cells from
those
individuals and create banks of cells
that could be used as an off-the-shelf
approach
for what we would call like a universal
donor and we called a universal donor
similar to the the idea of um blood
banking where if you are
uh o
o negative if you're a negative you can
give blood to anybody because there's
nobody who will reject your blood
and the same idea here if we can get if
we can identify the right universal
donor frank k cells that one donor could
be given to anybody
so
how do we do that um so we really poured
through the literature around what makes
a good donor and we settled on some
things like having high qb content
that those have been
associated with better outcomes in most
transplant studies
we want all the the inhibitory cures to
be licensed that's what gives nk cells a
more functional
phenotype we want
patients donors to have had prior cmv
because that's what induces a particular
protein called nkg2c and make some
adaptive nk cells and we want to make
sure that that those
donors have adequate numbers of nk cells
that they proliferate okay so we've been
screening them so we've been working for
about a year and a half with a group
called be the match biotherapies which
is the
um sort of non-transplant arm of the
nmdp national marrow donor program and
so nmdp if you go to a bone marrow drive
they're the ones who swab your cheek and
put you in a database and so they've got
a database of hundreds of thousands of
individuals who already have had a lot
of the testing that we would need
and so we've been working in about a
year and a half to
do all of this screening and collection
and collect batches of
products
from these donors and then expand them
for therapy and
then from each individual you can
actually collect enough material to
treat
dozens if not hundreds of patients
so we've really just started on that
we've treated the first six patients now
with the universal donor nk cells
we have a couple of patients that we've
been able to
to follow those cells by hla haplotype
differences
and see that the nk cells after we
infuse them go to really really high
numbers are sustained for a couple of
weeks and then drop back down again
afterwards so we're really encouraged by
this as an approach this will greatly
streamline um the clinical trials
process
lots of patients can't wait for nk cells
to be manufactured for them they need
the cells now
and it also has
significantly reduced our cost of goods
probably by
eighty percent uh in terms of of the
cost per dose uh of nk cells that we
were delivering
so another thing that we need to try to
overcome for solid tumors is
the presence of tgf-beta and so we
decided to try
just as a
a simple experiment in the lab if we add
tgf-beta to our
culture method
maybe we could suppress the cells that
are sensitive and the ones that are
resistant would grow out and we could
generate these tgf-beta resistant nk
cells
well turns out the tj beta does nothing
to cell proliferation
it only inhibits cytokine production and
a little bit of cytotoxicity but it
doesn't impact the proliferation of the
cells so it completely failed from that
perspective of what we thought was going
to happen
but what did happen is when the tgf-beta
was present for
the whole time of our culture then when
you took them out of that environment
they suddenly now are tgf-beta resistant
they make even more cytokine than they
did before
and they've completely shut off
this protein called samad 3 which is an
important part of tgf-beta signaling so
that's why they're now tjp beta
resistant they can't signal from the
cytokine
but they've been sort of revved up in
terms of their ability to make uh
further other functional effects
and surprisingly even when we're looking
at things like long-term cytotoxicity
um the green and the red in let's just
look at the bottom left-hand graph this
is kinetic killing
over a three-day period of an aml cell
line called kasumi and the green is the
wild type at low et ratios and the red
is the wild type at high e t ratios
the pink is the low e t ratio with tg
beta and printing and the blue is the
high e t ratio with tg beta imprinting
so the tgf beta cells are not just
um
able to make more cytokine they're not
just able to overcome tj beta but they
actually kill
long term even better
so we're working on that
to get it to the clinic in a dog model
the last thing i'll show you is is we've
adapted this approach to growing cells
from
from blood bank dogs
osu across the street
has a a doggy blood bank where they
collect blood all the time for their
their canine patients and we're doing
the same thing as we would for humans
take their buffy coat get rid of the t
cells expand them uh on our feeder cell
cryopreserve them and so we now have
about a half a dozen dogs
with cancer that we've treated with this
universal donor approach of tgf beta
resistance cells
so more to come
more for us to kind of optimize and we
now have a nice
wonderful model to use for how to better
deliver these cells
so with that i'll just say thank you to
an awful lot of people that i work with
um who
help in the lab um former lab members
who have developed a lot of this
um collaboratives that we've had all
across the world lucia sila is a
collaborator in brazil she's established
a whole program down there of delivering
nk cells
that we've published together with
university of montreal where we've
worked with
some gene modification
lots of foundations that have really
supported our work and people in the gmp
facility and regulatory ip and
operations that have helped us actually
get our clinical trials going
and with that
this is our team actually this is a
couple years ago we have a lot of new
members and some of these have moved on
but
a large team that all is necessary to
make this happen
and i will
move on to some questions
and thank you so much dr lee for your
time today and we will now start the
live q and a portion of this webinar if
you have any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions coming in dr lee
our first question
in your opinion can aim the medium plus
icsr supplement be used in expanding
pluripotent stem cell-derived nk cells
in feeder-free system
i think it's likely
um
so we we've actually used the feeder
the feeder cell system um to expand nk
cells that come from
ipscs uh and that approach is actually
what um what fade is using now in their
production so they use a feeder cell
approach and
once you get to the nk cell stage the
expansion part seems to be the same
whether the nk cells come from
ipscs or cord blood or hematopoietic
stem cells like um
[Music]
i'm liking on the company but uh encored
um
or from peripheral blood uh it doesn't
really matter the the proliferation part
is the same so i would expect that the
serum free media would work the same for
theirs the key is i think for them or
other companies that are ipsc related
is the
pre-enquestion piece what are you
growing the ipscs in and what what are
you doing your differentiation of ipscs
into nk cells from the nk cells on they
all seem to behave the same
thank you so much
and it looks like we have one more
question can you comment on the
potential of ipsc source nk cells as
compared to universal donor and key
styles
sure
um
so
trying to eliminate as much bias as i
have
the real differences are in
maturation and uniformity um i think
most of the ipsc-based companies would
would hang their hat on the fact that
when you start from a single ipsc every
batch you make is going to be uniform
and as i showed you in in our
in the slides that is a problem for nk
cell therapy is finding when you're
looking for donors
is the lack of uniformity that there's
there's a lot of genetic variability
there's a lot of um
experiential like every time you
experience different viruses you skew
your nk cells a different way and so you
have more variability what you gain in
peripheral blood um it or the universal
donor cells being from mature peripheral
blood
is the licensing and education of cells
so
one of the things is that nkg2c that i
mentioned um we almost never see that on
an nk cell until it's been exposed to
cmv
and it's not entirely clear yet how to
get an ipsc to do that
in vitro because
it's never been in a person who can
experience cmv so there are some real
differences um and i think we're just
gonna going to take time and some
comparisons to really see if those
differences matter from a therapeutic
perspective
thank you so much i want to thank our
audience for these great questions in
your opinion will genetic engineering
such as car and k be required to improve
potency of nk therapy
i don't think it's required i think it
is an approach that finally is gaining
some traction that can improve
um
specificity and can help target nk cells
to some tumor types that might be less
sensitive to the natural recognition
that in cases have
so
i think what we need to differentiate
from the rest of the t cell field is
that if i take t cells from a donor
it's highly unlikely that
that any or certainly no more than a few
hundredths of a percent of those cells
will ever naturally be able to recognize
the cancer
but so you have to give them a car you
have to put a car in to direct them to
the cancer
nk cells already recognize cancer that's
what they're known for is their ability
to recognize these danger signs that
enable them with rapid recognition of of
abnormal cells and so they don't have to
have anything to target them the the car
might help target them in some cases
but you're starting from a different
product and so i think there's there's
some real importance in differentiating
t cells from nk cells
thank you so much we have time for two
more questions can you talk more about
the potential of using nk cells for
solid tumor therapy why they may show
more promise than t cells for example
well one of those is what i just
mentioned that t cells don't naturally
recognize solid tumors unless you
engineer them with something to direct
them to a surface protein and when you
do that
one of the limitations of car
t-cell therapies
is that you have to find an antigen that
is uniformly
expressed on the tumor and isn't
expressed elsewhere in the body so that
you can target the tumor and not have
toxicities in other tissue and that's
been really hard to find for solid
tumors um we got kind of lucky actually
with leukemias that we chose an antibody
to cd19 and
and that the c19 antigen is
essentially dispensable you you can live
without it if you target every cell in
your body with cd19 you can still live
that's not true for most solid tumor
antigens where if you target
an antigen that's on lung cancer you may
end up targeting the rest of the lung or
or other tissues in the body so that's
been a little bit harder
so nk cells in contrast
as we showed above um that first slide
where i put nk cells with all those
different types of tumors and they
killed leukemias and
sarcomas and carcinomas and brain tumors
that's without any targeting that is
just the natural ability of nk cells to
recognize those cancer cells so i think
there may be broader applicability of of
nk cells to many different kinds of
solid tumors
even if they don't have the high
specificity that a car t cell would have
thank you so much now how do we further
improve the persistence of transplanted
nk cells in patients
good question and
um
[Music]
there's an answer to the question
there's a question to the question
so
persistence
has been linked to
car t cell efficacy
and some of the early nk cell
efficacy studies
only when you're thinking about
a single infusion so in the car t cell
space
you have a limited number of t cells
that you can harvest from a patient they
have active leukemia at the time you
you gene modify that into
your product and most of the time you
deliver the entire products to the
patient so you've got one chance
to make it work and those cells have to
attack the cancer and live
for three to six months for there to be
long-term disease controlled
the early studies that i showed you with
nk cells where they were derived from
apheresis you had one shot you had one
chance to infuse nk cells and they were
going to expand in vivo and had to
persist at least two to three weeks in
order to
have
evidence of a response
but now that we can grow and engineer
large numbers of universal donor and
case cells that are off the shelf we can
repeatedly infuse cells uh in most of my
clinical trials we've infused at least
three up to six and in one case up to 27
doses of nk cells so we don't need to
really work hard to engineer them to
persist we need to think of them
more like drugs that we dose at
intervals and we understand their
pharmacokinetics so that we know how
often to dose them and what context it
doesn't mean
that's that's kind of my opinion so i
think there may be some things we can do
to improve their persistence but i don't
know that that is really the answer
um it's really the answer is really in
shifting our thinking away from what we
learned about t cells
thank you so much dr lee for your time
today would you like to provide any
closing remarks before we go
um no i'm just uh just happy to have
been invited uh i feel very fortunate
that i shifted my uh emphasis from t
cells to nk cells uh a while ago
um and finally you know happy that nk
cells are getting some some uh
deserved attention so thanks for
inviting me
and dr lee thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
and i do want to take the time to thank
lab roots and our sponsor gibgo by
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted on will be on demand period
will be duress by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand laborats will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone stay safe
bye